Hello,
freak bitches think you're totally
right,
and the amount of discipline it'll
you'll need on two fronts is great.
But here's the other thing.
You're such a cunt.
No,
no,
no.
Here's
the last one.
Real stakes.
What does that mean?
Stakes man?
One hundred percent.
But you get,
you lose your beard.
You had somebody.
Oh yeah,
you have
met in my life.
I asked you for what happened with BMI
is a measurement of the height and
weight,
but I said,
okay,
you got the height,
his height,
so just fucking measures height.
I'm six foot four man line.
There was no question.
It was like we all knew that,
hey,
it's time
to say
hey man,
did
you did you did.
Is it was after you right now for
reinforcing negative stereotypes.
Oh,
you're so of.
And when they got the national it was
going
to ask how many tweets did you get
calling you a?
Well,
I've got my nipples pierced diaper for
dates.
It's true.
Your voice breaking like Kevin
mccallister and
I said these boys basketball game you
did on your own
fucking play the guitar when you guys
are punching,
eating pizza.
I was down when you went to Asia for
four months to get out of a bag.
So at that point it became him taking
this opportunity,
going to denver,
being with Dwayne,
getting paid into muscle farm thing and
then the whole thing with connor
happened on the TV show before this,
before any of this happened,
conor mcgregor started calling him a
columbus snake because me and connor had
one conversation.
We're sitting there and he goes,
he goes,
man,
congratulations on Tj defending his belt
because he was still on her team is last
title defense.
And I go,
thanks.
He goes,
but what's up with Dwayne?
Say that no one on your team wants to be
champions.
That's weird.
I said,
oh,
he's just bitter because you know,
he's trying to get everyone to go out to
his camp,
but you know,
he's just being a hater,
this and that.
And he goes.
He took that little bit of,
of,
of drama between me and Dwayne.
Dwayne saying that no one on our team
want to be your champions,
including cody,
who sent them a text,
a tweet that said,
hey,
keep my name out your mouth and you're
like a jealous girlfriend or whatever.
And he said he took that one little
thing and then next time you saw tj he
goes,
oh,
there's a snake in the grass and just
built it in this big thing.
So that means either how well he is so
good at seeing people,
right?
Yeah.
So that took like what really happened,
which is tj got paid to go somewhere
else me and saying,
all right,
fine,
if you're going to do that,
cool.
But like,
you know,
if you're on that team,
you're on that team.
And then then connor turned the public
around on him
because it came out later after the
thing and so then you became the victim
and then he.
And now Tj is new stories that I,
I,
I got mad that he was trained with Duane
Ludwig and I kicked him off the team.
Well,
you know,
Tj now has a snake as his logo.
I know on the ultimate fighter he
brought in snakes,
you know what I mean?
He just,
he's at home with it,
you know,
he's cool with it.
So it's all good.
We're rewinding back a little bit like
if you want to be friends,
let's be friends,
but don't,
don't,
don't lie.
Do you think it was a good idea to write
that memo?
Like if you had to go back again,
if you were in front of your computer
and you're ready,
press send,
would you uh,
maybe I would wait for my year end
bonus.
Oh Man.
I mean I think I would have pushed
harder,
even harder on the diversity of
programs,
although I met with them personally and
I kept pinging them and I sent so many
emails.
I'm just trying to have a discussion
about this.
And I went through multiple other
programs and sent this document,
this exact document to them.
So it's really unclear what I could've
done differently.
But I,
for example,
I didn't know so much about the
underground conservative network before
all of this.
And Google you mean?
Yeah.
And even within silicon valley,
there was attempts to sort of connect
them between companies,
but there's so much verification that
you need to go through to be able to
join one of these.
You have to have a pseudonym.
Uh,
I mean you don't need to be totally
anonymous,
but you know,
you,
you don't want because there's active
attempts to try to infiltrate these
groups.
Really?
Yeah.
I,
this happens a lot where they'll try to
join a group,
act as if they're one of them and then
just record what's happening and then
expose them
and you know,
you can take anything out of context and
it will be shown as you know,
racism or something.
Sure.
What means.
Think of what we said,
well,
not you but me joking around in this
conversation.
You could clearly take something I've
said out of context and make them a
monster,
but if you're in an email and you're
complaining about some sort of diversity
program
yet,
what they often do is they will find
someone that they disagree with and then
they'll scour through their entire
history at Google and all the emails
that they've.
And try to look for some way to
blacklist them or show that this person
is evil,
therefore they should be fired.
It's horrible.
And supposedly this is happening in
other companies too.
And they even have like these automated
scripts to try to find these negative
things on people that they don't like.
You remember the verizon ringback tone?
Yeah.
Used to be called people up sometimes.
You still call people up and we play a
song.
Yeah,
I guess they still have it right?
You still have king of Rock,
you call other king.
Oh
my favorite is when you had to get move.
You had to get a good buddy.
Run DMC you had for a year.
I am beautiful.
Christina Aguilera.
We would just being like a normal
conversation with like adults and it's
that thing which is
I've always loved that song.
Good tickets.
I like some.
Sometimes I'd like things and I don't
like that.
I feel pressured,
not like them,
you know?
I'm like,
why?
How come I can't like that song?
It's a beautiful song.
It's,
is it does it too girly so that what it
is that.
What's going on?
A lot of prejudice.
That's how I feel with Taylor swift.
I was blaring her new song the other day
and I was at a red light and I was like,
God damn,
I got to roll up my windows.
You go boy.
Saying that Shit.
Who gives a fuck?
It's weird.
You got to be scared to sing things out.
I was playing that one sia song in here
after you left one day and you came back
in like when you get
tight,
tight.
Hashtag black twitter.
It's the hot shit.
Yeah man.
There's like a lot of shit that I
probably shouldn't.
Like.
What's your biggest latest guiltiest
pleasure?
Um,
I like Taylor swift.
Yeah,
I like her music.
I like.
I like so your team tailor like Justin
Bieber.
I like his voice.
It's got a beautiful voice.
A couple of his songs are right.
Kid could see his fucking ass off.
I heard some people are into that kind
of music.
They're upset right now because Justin
timberlake is rumored or he's going to
be doing vocals on the new foo fighters
album,
but he's just doing some background.
You won't even know it's him,
but his name made it out in a blog post
or something.
This guy is not going to do.
This is timberlake.
He's a smart guy.
He's not going to do anything stupid.
If he does do that,
he's going to smash it.
He wouldn't do it if he didn't think
he'd get smashed at worse.
Yeah,
we'll just smash it.
he's great.
I don't want white people shit on him.
He's like one of the best,
most talented to Hanson.
Too Tall,
too.
Pretty to rich.
He danced around too.
Good at dancing.
I don't like it.
Do not like it.
Yeah,
guys don't like some handsome fellow
dances.
Real good and sings his ass off.
Fuck that.
So people are hating.
He just gets all the poison dances.
Fucking dancer can't like dancing too
much if you're a dude,
but it's that same thing.
The same reason why you're not supposed
to like that.
I am beautiful song.
It's Goddamn beautiful song,
but you know,
people refer you to be like,
you know,
enter Sandman,
which is great to get this balance in
this life.
Right?
You want a little ozzy osborne every now
and then.
You want a little shell crow?
I liked a little sheryl crow.
I'm hauling notes all day.
I can't get enough of hall and oates.
I can't go for that.
Got You.
No,
no.
Ken Do Hala notes.
Old School son.